you feel very sorry for all these immigrants that are coming into our country
right the ones who are being persecuted
the ones who are running away from their countries
because they have no food to eat
they have nowhere to go
their houses are all taken away
I know that you feel very
very sorry for them
but I got some flashing news for you
and I need you to listen
because I came from a place that was destroyed by the same ideology
feel sorry for these people
but you're supporting the same policies that destroyed their country
we Americans are going to end up just like them
if we don't start taking action right now
more than half of these immigrants come from Venezuela
go ask them if they're able to purchase a firearm in Venezuela
go ask them why they're leaving their countries
go ask them how many good citizens were killed by the state police
that are now controlling everything and you
and you're not able to say what you need to say
you don't have any more freedom of speech
you just have to say amen to everything that Maduro (their dictator) says
and still you want to stop American people from purchasing firearms
don't you understand that having the right to defend yourself
our Second Amendment
is actually protecting our First Amendment
the most important amendment of all
if we're not able to defend ourselves
our government can take away our most precious thing
which is our freedom
you keep promoting welfare like it's the best thing in the world
the government is actually so happy about it
all because it's easy to control people
when you give them some sort of money here and there
when you buy them their food
they actually want this from us
we need to run away
for any type of welfare
I understand some people will need it eventually
but this gotta be like
for an urgent situation
we should not be celebrating welfare
you create that in this country
and now you come up saying that you have solutions for it
and people are blindly accepting it
this type of government is the same type of government that destroyed Venezuelan
in other countries
like mine Brazil
when the government controls your food
your housing your income
you are not in good hands
stop believing that the government is here to help you
they're not and especially
this government's trying to erase the middle class
they just want to divide us into rich and poor
and when they're able to do that here in America
I'll tell you my friend
that's the day America is over
you're supporting policies that discredit the family
as an important institution for our society
you're trying to take away parents rights on their children
they've already infiltrated the press
they've already infiltrated schools and universities
and they're just ready for you all to give in
but we should not
I need you to open your eyes and see
and take these countries as an example
why are these people here
what are they running away from
I need you to think about that for a second
and start thinking about the things that you're supporting and defending
here in America
and you'll understand that the end result for all of the things that you support
is the same thing that happened to these people's countries
and now look at them
risking their lives to get in here
I'm not saying it's correct
I don't agree with illegal immigration
but I do know that
one of the biggest arguments of people who say they agree with that
they're poor people
blah blah is this like oh
you're so heartless
don't you look at them and feel sorry for them
like they came from such bad countries
all of this stuff
so here I am
telling you yes
you're right
alright they did run away from their countries
but I want you to ask yourself a
a question that goes in depth of why
why did they leave their countries
what happened there
and when you start studying about it
you'll see the truth